[Music]
joining me today is a stand-up comic who
apparently scares a whole bunch of
people with his choice of comedy words
which can be very dangerous
oh and Benjamin welcome to the Reuben
report thanks for having me man it's an
honor you're scary comedy words you're
freaking people out I see people angry
at you on Twitter all the time each week
I make a commitment to not mention
Twitter and then somehow it just rears
its ugly 140-character head into yeah
it's like the mob and Godfather yeah oh
yeah it's always for I'm not even a
troll or anything it's just for saying
things that I think everyone would agree
with I'm like yeah three-year-olds can't
be trans and everyone's like what and
I'm like okay so then I just start
fighting yeah so I want to get into like
some of the issues you talk about and
all that but first just I I don't talk
to I've talked to a whole bunch of
stand-ups on here but I don't talk to a
lot of people that are sort of in the
game sort of the level you are at right
now like really kind of like in the
thick of their career in it right now
what possessed you I asked you before
you started you're a couple years you
know gonna be 37 did you say what
possessed you to become a stand-up comic
well I I was a classical piano player
and I was in college and I my dad taught
public speech still teaches public
speech so I've always been comfortable
onstage and I would play piano at
weddings but I would just get hammered
and write songs for people and uh and so
my friends in college were like you
should open for this dude who's coming
I'm like who is it they're like I don't
know what he's been is is this dude
named Kevin Hart
so we were in a cafeteria and and I
opened for him and it was so fun then I
was like okay I'm gonna do that you know
but I have to go to law school and do
the normal thing and then there's an
economic downturn and my adviser was
like since its down anyway just take a
year and do what you want to do and I
was like yeah maybe I will do that and
then I just never stopped and who was
this advisor does his name was dr. Scott
because I was in World War two history a
history major focused on World War two
and so I got really close with him and
I'm because he taught a class called the
Holocaust and so that was such an
emotional class I think there was this
weird bonding of trauma so we've just
got really close and I'm so I trusted
and I just and then I met you know Nick
Swardson and Adam Sandler early on and
so I could make a living and it's so
funny how like when you're saying like
I'm pissing people off on Twitter it's
for things that I was almost called a
hack four or five years ago like men and
women being different yeah like back in
the day everyone's like all in so broad
he's such a hack and now it's like you
cannot say there's a difference in
gender and I'm like if you just don't
move the Overton Window just keep
sliding right over yeah well I didn't
say in the oh it's not do the Overton
Window had shifted it's that it has
shattered at this point nothing that
made sense five years ago in a Comedy
sense actually makes sense anymore
oh yeah like watch boys and saddles or
just I watch it like a month ago and
ever I mean first off date the way the
amount of times that they say the N word
of course is off the charts but just
everything of every stereotype literally
every service time you can think of in a
modern sense is in that movie they could
not make that movie right now
no and I think people don't understand
sarcasm it's almost like late onset
autism like I was doing a bit the other
day this is what got me in this heat
with this Shaun White character is uh I
was doing a bit about being a
progressive slave owner yeah progressive
slave owners like the problem of slavery
was uh it's only black people which is
unfair I want all the people if you
can't outrun the nets and the harpoons
your mind yeah and people thought I was
promoting slavery and I'm like I think
not not assuming that I know that's bad
is like almost scarier to me
yeah well I'm like I do another bit
about not having white pride or white
shame and I'm like I've never done
anything to anybody
my last slave was in oh wait you know
thanks a lot Obama you know and people
like what I'm like do you think
someone's knock knock who's there like
do you think there's a door here right
like how do you not see that mechanism
of comedy what do you think has happened
there because I noticed that for me when
I was in in the thick of stand up which
really from was about 98 to around 2010
and lesson in these last couple years
what I noticed a change when cell phones
started popping up enclosure and then
there was the you know obviously the
Michael Richards incident and and then
everyone who's video is hating
everything I noticed that comics were
distracted all the time even if I saw
one guy just on his phone in the back
look that would bother me even if I was
crushed
you know you may not get a million
people I'm killing it but the one guy
like that was something that shifted
comedy force it's the lowercase I it's
it's the bitten apple man it's this
isn't biblical [ __ ] right here you know
it's like the lowercase I represents
narcissism without even the strength of
it but you know it's like that uh
there's a book the Screwtape Letters by
I think CS Lewis where it's it's it's
two demons talking to each other about
how to get souls it's kind of comedic
but pretty profound and one of the point
one of the demons is like it's worse to
want to do something terrible and not
even have the balls to do it like that
lowercase I iPhone iMac III but it's a
lower case and then the bitten Apple is
like the fall of man and I have an
iPhone I'm on attack all the time I'm
not judging or being above it but that
creates this environment where stupid
people are now entitled where they're
like well as someone who knows nothing I
think and and people listen to you or
nothing that gives you extra privilege
yeah because you're yeah because my
smart privilege is really showing I
guess but it's like this weird like
people that don't know the definition of
words you know I think we're 20 20 years
away from people just being like no not
not not now I'm speaking Japanese like
they almost don't care it all about the
skill set how much you this you think is
actually just a phenomenon of the online
world cuz I'm a firm believer that out
there in the real world and when you do
what we're doing right now you really
can bring out the best in people and
that they're not all hysterical all's
well yeah I mean I live firmly in the
real world like my brothers in arborists
when I'm not on the road I'm literally
doing lumberjack work with a bunch of
vets so it's like I live in the
mountains in a small town like I know
the sanity of people and I also tour so
much that I know I'm not offending
communities you know like I'll finish a
show and a bunch of like inner-city
black dudes are like you're the only
white dude I find phony now man that was
great and then you go online and it's
just a bunch of white Yale chicks being
like how dare you and I'm like but it
almost doesn't matter because the online
world is so powerful like it gets me
fired it gets me my my it'll make my
income go down so that's when it becomes
real to me yeah where people can be like
it's cyber but is it I think it's
becoming its own organism yeah so we
literally can make your income go down
you are not making that up so just in
the last what two months because of a
comment I think that started on Twitter
yeah you got a gig canceled for a couple
grand I mean what it was about seventy
five yeah 7,500 7,500 bucks you had a
gig canceled at UConn so can you tell me
about that yeah so I was having an
argument online where I revealed a very
problematic view that I don't think
three-year-olds can be transgendered and
then especially once they started
talking about hormone blockers like you
know my instinct to protect was kicking
in and I was like this is wrong you know
and people started calling me
transphobic and I'm like that's not
years old three three three
yeah and now the kids like six and this
guy is fairly powerful in podcasting I
think it's been an NPR a lot and you
know so I get all these what used to be
trolls like these little were they eggs
yeah now or like blue checkmark people
yeah and I'm like you wait a minute
you're a writer at an Amazon show and
you're gonna call me human garbage
because of a child but I don't back down
I'm like okay so do you believe a
six-year-old side but they identify I'm
like dude I identified as a dog like I
thought was a spaceman I was an autobot
right yeah and it's like because it also
completely derails actual you know
adults making the decision to
transgender I'm like what you're doing
it's almost like the Spacey thing where
you almost equated being gay with like
liking kids and you're like okay that's
such stuff back it's good ten years you
know I'm like that's crazy and and so
then people just kept coming at me and I
wouldn't stop you know I'm like no I
know people that want to kill you guys
because it's child abuse I know I know
boys that are rape survivors it became
trained killers in Afghanistan that
literally like just please don't do this
there's people that hate you
and and because I used to do it when it
I might have missed where you go that
boys that were no I have friends
you know because I live near a rehab
facility for heroin and a lot of them
are vets and and they eating the trauma
that yeah they like when when a when a
grown man is saying that he's gonna pump
hormones into his little boys so they
never go through puberty there's people
that want that want to hurt that guy
because that I used to do a bit about
when it was the Catholic Church back in
the day it's weird how it swung because
I used to just rip on the right for some
of these corruptions stuff where I'm
like you know I was uh I was an altar
boy I knew something was up when they
said wear a dress light a candle and
drink some wine I'm like I was had a
date yeah and and I'm like now you guys
are encouraging this behavior and I'm
like and and it just kept going until I
got this this email that was like due to
you know recent Twitter stuff like we
have to disinvite you to UConn and I was
so I posted that because that's happened
to me before with stuff I've been asked
by agents to take down certain tweets
that looking back we're absolutely valid
and and so I posted that just because
people think we're lying but people like
me and you in this industry almost
Canaries in coal mines sometimes rhyme
like no they are trying to shut you up
yeah and so then my agent dropped me and
like so and you were with the pre you
don't up the name of you see yeah yeah
yeah yeah you this is one of the like 10
years yeah I've known with the same
manager in the same agent for 10 years
so I'm not one of these problematic
clients like I I've never left anybody
yeah and so and I just done this like a
pilot with truTV like a month before so
it's not like I was even on a downward
dang and and I guess I just crossed so
many lines that they're like and and
they're good guys you know I'm not mad
at the agents and I'm mad at the system
that makes it so comedians now have to
push an agenda right like this endless
cowardice that's sort of middle
management people then so they're just
like alright we're gonna cut Benjamin
we'll just let them go because we don't
want to deal with the heat regardless of
whether you're killing it in the clubs
they don't care because my twitter is
been going up my YouTube subscriptions
have quadrupled in a month yeah and it's
like that doesn't matter to them it's
this outrage ponzi-scheme it's an
accurate song it's almost like a bernie
made
thing without Rage where it's like you
have this Ponzi scheme that has to grow
and find new victims or else it all
collapses and then you have to read
Thomas soul and realize there's some
economic issues but uh well we're
getting sold on the show oh he's one my
heroes I'm black redneck white liberals
one of the best books I've ever read in
my life I've been working on this guy
literally for three years we're going up
to Stanford to do it oh that's genius
yeah
do you remember sort of a moment on
stage when you saw the Overton Window
crash like was it a specific bit like I
remember once being on stage and I used
to do a bit it was a trend I just
mentioned the Autobots but it was a
Transformers bit you say something about
how jazz was the autobot who was black
and he kind of talked in drive and I
used to do this an impression of jazz
and I would say the n-word at the end
yeah but I was doing an impression of a
fictitious cartoon character yeah that
was the whole purpose of it he used to
get huge laughs I remember doing it on
stage one I had a Gotham comedy club in
New York City yeah and the audience kind
of it was a different reaction than I
had ever gotten and I was like all right
I'm done with that one and and I just
let it go do you do you have a moment
where you saw something shift for me it
was a slow it was a death by a thousand
cuts but I remember one joke in
particular that because in LA a lot of
my friends are gay so I would write a
lot of jokes around like that I that
would make them laugh you know and then
my and and I remember I'd go to certain
areas and there'd be these like
housewife type suburban brain-dead
idiots and I would do a similar joke and
they would turn so hard I'm like bro I
wrote that like in a gay bar I think
other bits the bit was uh I was like
yeah it's affected a lot of communities
you know but no one got hit harder than
the vampires and I used to do it now
it's hilarious because it's not anti-gay
remotely it's like wait a minute how do
you get this from blood and sex that's
all I've done for a thousand years you
can't put a condom on a Fang
I don't know who I just killed you know
and I remember getting drones and being
like that's a brilliant joke I hate you
guys but but then I would I would keep
it inside though I wouldn't turn on the
crowd I try not to turn the crowd for
being stupid but I remember just being
like this is getting worse and worse and
worse I've seen Zach Galifianakis say
the n-word on stage
six without any hater malice obviously
and that and that didn't get the same
reaction and now you can't even say you
can't even be a certain type of person
on stage yeah what do you make of just
like the comics in general like the
state of comedy to me right now is
pretty off bunch of [ __ ] these guys
that I used to love and admire many of
whom I know dude they're cowards and I'm
looking at them now and they're
preaching all day long whining like
Jimmy Kimmel and all these guys I'm like
dude you guys are cowards and and and
history eats these people it's not like
it's the only a matter of time I'm like
you are a comedian it's like if I played
football so it's like if you play on the
offensive line you don't throw the ball
like we're comedians we're supposed to
push envelopes there's no line for us we
let the crowd figure out who they are by
hyperbole and you know there's that
quote I exaggerate to clarify you know
and and then you see these guys talking
about self-censorship like Trevor Noah
talking about self-centered censorship
and stuff and I'm like bro I had your
back when they came at you mm-hmm
and now in one night like two years nine
million later you're like talking this
[ __ ] but that just give you a compliment
I'm so happy to the people like you
exist because you can get depressed with
this stuff you know like you and Shapiro
and Rogan and Crowder and there's people
that are they're really intelligent
people that aren't going down this hole
that just were a lifeline to me because
I felt like everyone was going insane
and I still think they are but at least
I know that you know I try to ask myself
am I crazy you know I'm like you know if
one is good every comic ever is walking
around thinking you know but if it's
like if one guy calls you an [ __ ]
he might be an [ __ ] but the third guy
you might be an [ __ ] you know so I'm
like I'm killing onstage but like the
community's starting to get weird but
then so I'm just glad that you guys
exist because I know a lot of professors
that love your show too that are like
they want they want that dialogue that
marketplace of ideas and lately it's
just been like what color is your skin
how much do you like hell yeah well
thanks I mean I appreciate that and
that's why I wanted to have you on and
that's I think why we sort of got in the
loop you know we're very much in that
same loop you know Twitter and there's a
lot of crossover
our audiences and all that you mentioned
the the college thing and professors you
come from two professors to professor
SUNY system State University of New York
I'm a product of Binghamton not SUNY
Plattsburgh ER here oh and you and your
parents from this we go yeah and the
professors right now are going through a
hard time because people that thought
they were liberal it's kind of like what
you went through and what I went through
where it's like you think that the
personal liberty aspect of liberalism
which was like Pro gay rights stuff like
that but then you're like I'm also pro
private guns you know I don't I think
that citizens should have guns and I'm
like no but not that one and I'm like
and then you see how saturated leftism
is on colleges where people are now just
judged based on their skin and sexuality
where it's like well as a black person
who's gay and you're like you never read
Martin Luther King jr. yeah like letter
from a Birmingham jail or any of that
stuff like the whole point was not to
think this way and it's it's intense so
yeah but the good news is is I was only
I was pretty sad for a few weeks but
then I just kind of started doing my own
thing and I had self-produced
an hour special in England I just put up
for sale myself at vimeo.com slash Owen
Benjamin if anyone wants to get feed the
bear excellent self-promotion thank you
a very subtle we normally do it at the
end not me math I break all those rules
you have no rules that's your thing my
only rules no rules I just what if I
just killed myself
that's my only rule man it's good for
clicks yeah well that's the web that's
what I was always against anarchy I
always make fun of like everybody's a
Michael malleus and one joke I said to
him I was like I said the problem of the
Enter key is a bad leadership you need
help it's like if there's no rules how
do you have an organization yeah what I
make of a guy like now so I had my did
you see our interview by any chance I
prob into all your interviews I never
watched any of them that's why I didn't
even know yeah I always listened this is
the place we do I am digging it man here
we go very college like the bat is the
six-foot-seven guy who's bad at
basketball that's a taunt
are you bad at basketball oh yeah girls
pick and then a disappointment oh I
would have killed to be six foot seven
that's a whole thing but malice I I
really like talking to him I didn't know
didn't know what to expect really but he
strikes me as one he has the heart of a
comic action oh yeah he's what it struck
me is he wants to throw some [ __ ] out
there kind of see what sticks and then
explore it like and that's what a comic
is really supposed to do and that's what
we see so little of these days yeah I
think a lot of really good like Dave
Smith is also really funny and he's
particularly mentioned him to me yeah
yeah where it's a lot of these guys I
find Crowder's hilarious you know it's
like when when someone says to write
there's so many types mm-hmm you know
and I think that there is no leftist
comedian that isn't lying in my opinion
it's piracy like you have to think like
you have to poke you have to move like
you're living out of a suitcase like you
can't possibly be like what is the group
think it goes completely against what
your job is you have to be able to tilt
the other direction when things go like
this you know you can be a liberal
comedian but leftist there's no way you
can't there's no cop stalingrad funny
bone yeah I'd be insane like he killed
the first dude to stop clapping got
killed but is that why this is so
dangerous right now like I can see the
passion you're talking about it with and
I feel it when I talk to all my friends
that are kind looks like everyone can
feel this thing like when comedy dies in
a society and we just replace it with
screaming that seems like it's pretty
fertile ground for some other stuff to
go really wrong oh yeah because because
words are what keeps us from killing
each other where if you debate an idea
up here then that you don't have to kill
each other and so provocative ideas and
people aren't born knowing what they are
what they think like that's another
thing that I have a problem with it's
like oh you said the wrong thing it's
like I might be wrong but I'm not lying
it's my point and I will find the line
but sometimes I thought Colin Kaepernick
was Puerto Rican for like a year you
know helped enough likewise the Puerto
Rican taking a knee is that have to do
with Puerto Rico I'm dead serious
and then I figured out it was a black
situation and you know so you're always
trying to figure it out what what about
the club's like what's actually going on
in the clubs and so like management that
kind of thing like I've always I've
always dug that improv like that I had a
recent thing with one of the employees
but it turned out to be this bizarre
thing that
happened because I just lost my agent
well I guess they like they wanted to
switch a week but I didn't have an agent
they didn't wait to be told anything
back so I assumed it was like some sort
of I still don't really know what
happened but they seemed cool but I'm
gonna break away from that too I just
think with the internet and your own fan
base you can just do small theaters and
rock clubs and stuff even though I love
comedy clubs but it's it's it is
political and I think that like if you
don't have an agent it's it's not that
easy
yeah so nobody has called you and been
like alright so see a drop yeah you know
people have offered it rep me but it's
it's another weird thing that happened
is a lot of these mid-level agencies got
gobbled up by the big guys yeah so now
it's basically just Walmart Target and
it used to have there was all these
agencies and now it's just you ta CAA
WME and others like six of them yeah and
I think that there's a real push to not
break ranks you know and I'm I can't go
with that because if you look at the
late night comedy hosts they're all the
same party so that's where I wanted to
go because you tweeted that image right
I saw that image going around of all the
late-night host yeah basically it's
pretty much all white guys not I know we
don't care about identity politics but
I'm just paint I do bro what yeah I'm
just painting this for the average force
of course it's basically it's all these
sort of 40-ish 250 ish white guys and
then Trevor Noah and then Larry Wilmore
who's not in late-night anymore but that
but your point and I think what a bunch
of other people picked up on and it is
every single one of these guys think the
same way and I thought that was really
interesting because in an odd way I was
looking through it I'm looking at
everybody I was thinking man Bill Maher
is probably the most centrist of this
crew yeah which is a crazy proposition
crazy yeah and and yeah I got 30,000
retweets and still Hollywood agencies
and stuff are like yeah there's no
market for that what does that tell you
in light of just the Weinstein thing and
just the way Hollywood's kind of
hypocrite right now yeah it's like what
are they doing what do you think they're
actually doing spiraling like it makes
no business sense they're losing out
on you know like yeah my I'm selling my
my our and it's doing fine I'm like do
up I think it's almost like certain
gatekeeper positions when Butte when a
technology exists it starts eliminating
those positions I think universities are
almost starting to get they're starting
to lose hey what makes them great and I
think that's when they get on this moral
condemnation kick you know like like
some of the smartest people I meet or
like truck drivers because they listen
to your show and Peterson and you know
all these lecture series is for a dollar
you know and and then you go to Yale and
you're just told that white men are the
reason Halloween is about slavery
you know just nonsense yeah and I think
they're just trying to hold on to a
position that is just not gonna stay
like I think all of Hollywood you know
Warner Brothers is because they needed
sunshine and giant cameras like we have
those cameras now in our pockets and a
distribution platform in the air but yet
these people were gonna tell me that
that I can't dress is you know a like a
big Mexican hat or else it's sad I don't
know I didn't know what they're talking
about now I was gonna offer you some
tequila behind you but that that's
cultural appropriation had to be a fan
only drink vodka berry some clear vodka
well I'm a glacier monkey I've never
heard that phrase before I know I think
I might have pointed did you just make
that up well I was ripping on a Canadian
the other day somebody was yelling I was
Canadian
and I called I called her a maple leaf
eating snow monkey and that kind of
stuck in my head yeah one of the other
times I noticed that something was
changing in the clubs was that I noticed
that heckling started getting people
kicked out of the clubs which for the
first many years that I always loved
hecklers always look I didn't love him
if I was on the best tear of my life and
a heckler started I would always use it
and I always loved it a heckard and the
heckler never beat me you just know how
to do it if you're live in your present
you have the mic they're there to see
you that if that person beats you you
need to find another life's real life
it's real it's like it's like that's why
people want to see you live because it's
you can see all the bits on YouTube but
come see something really go down yeah
you know and you never know what's going
to happen
but did you did you notice that also
that then they'd start kicking hecklers
out I always back to your original point
I think it's about the phone like with
the invention of the phone I think a lot
of comedians felt very vulnerable that
if they were working on a new joke
someone could embarrass them and then
that started creating this weird world
of like don't let things be natural
because I could be embarrassed but I
used to be a heckler at a Renaissance
Faire in high school really like I was
in a stock and I would and people would
pay money to throw tomatoes in my face
so the more deeply I could hurt someone
the more money I made and I was just
with gypsies all day long and I was 17
and that's when I learned that it isn't
what you are it's what you have pride in
that can be used against you you know
like a giant fat person doesn't care if
you call him fat it's someone like me
right now I was like 10 pounds
overweight cuz he has a new kid and he's
not sleeping enough you know like I
would spiral if some coffee fat but a
giant fat guy lost all the baby weight
yet that's when I still got baby weight
bro that sucks
yeah if you don't sleep enough you just
crave chocolate so it's like that's what
can get someone it's like you know the
super chiseled guys you know imply that
they're gay like a happy gay couple
don't care if you call them gay it's the
dudes that are like super like trying to
be like Swayze Road house you know it's
like that and I would do that 10 hours a
day just getting crushed with tomatoes
and I mean that's your sitcom right
there I mean have you wrote that yeah
that's it no I was getting credible
like what great rich stuff just gone
over there yeah I mean that's incredible
that's how you got into stand-up that's
like the most perfect thing I've ever
heard and I didn't even know I was
getting in the standup it was just a
summer job I was working in the turkey
leg booth and I this one gypsy realized
very funny the turkey legs are huge
there's a lot to everyone oh its turkey
legs yeah and uh yeah I feel like people
even get mad when we killed turkeys
because they're such [ __ ] you know
like have you seen wild turret like do
you hang with wild turkeys ever not I am
landlocked here in LA there's not a lot
of foul well I'm in the mountains have
you ever you know want to know what it's
like to be a man yeah I got my chickens
back there I hear you have chickens all
have tension against the only have three
chickens I used to have three chickens I
wanted a ninth
bro okay no but like turkeys are like
dicks yeah so when you kill them even
vegans are like yeah that's good kill
bro but so then I was good at like
handling customers and so someone threw
me in the stocks and I just died I did
pretty good I started beating the joust
in attendance you know cuz you gotta
take the highest thing probably right
yeah those guys can be real arrogant
haha and because you also got to lose I
can't just always win as the heckler I
can't like pretend like it's okay when I
get hit with the tomato like I don't
care about the tomato there has to be
stakes like if you hit me I'm humiliated
even though I wasn't really but I did
set it up where someone could
potentially win and so I created this
this little world that so I really
understand hacking and drawing like
really understand it yeah wait we
somehow should be shifted all over the
place there that was a heck of a map we
just did there but they're coming from
academic parents I think is interesting
were you was education like oh he's part
of growing up and talking about this
stuff and figuring out what freedom is
and all that oh yeah man I was like it
my birthdays was always I could go to
book warehouse and get any books I
wanted you know we didn't have a TV I
played piano all day it was just the
most idea rich awesome upbringing I
could imagine that almost bites me in
the ass a little now because I know what
words mean and [ __ ] like that
yeah the words to action thing has
become crazy right that people think
that words are action well the easiest
thing to do with that is just do that
and go word or facepunch can I go word
you go oh you know you're lying yeah I
mean like words being equated with
violence is the craziest most that that
could end our civilization if you say
that that a criticism is the same as
that as a hit alright so we're sort of
talking about the importance of words
and obviously a comic is a wordsmith we
were talking before and I mentioned
something about liberals vers leftists
and you were saying how much you liked
Crowder and one of the things that I
talked to Crowder about all the time is
that I wish that he would focus more on
leftist than liberals because I want
those things separated I am a liberal
but I am NOT a leftist yeah I think
about this a lot and
I think that I agree with you totally
about the difference between leftism and
and then there's also difference between
being a liberal and being liberal yeah
because liberal I'm I'm a liberal person
like it's a it's a personality trait of
openness you know there's a little bit
of chaos in your life you know my shoes
aren't always tied someone gives me a
new idea I'm like aha let's think about
that you change when you need to but
like a leftist is groupthink identity
politics it's actually very close to
like white nationalism it's just the
inverse of it right so that's the
horseshoe theory that everyone's always
talking abut like a liberal on Twitter I
don't mock liberals I always say leftist
wars are all mocked the DNC because
they're corrupt institution in my
opinion but like the Liberals have a
tough spot right now because that the
words are getting so weird like because
I know people who call themselves
liberals that are acting like leftists
and I the lines are so all over the
place because a lot of times a liberal
does not act liberal you know they act
like they put people in these holes kind
of like what your experience was I've
listened to show a long time like you
you are a Jewish gay married man and
you're not allowed to have certain
opinions about some of these things if
it doesn't follow the exact narrative
they want that's the opposite of being
liberal like what they're doing yeah and
so that's why it's a very interesting
time to be alive right and by the way
those two adjectives they use their to
me are the least interesting things
about me those happen to be two things
that the identity is saying I'm saying
like those things but they're I would
rather sit across from somebody tell
them what I think and and be judged for
that but oh yeah I almost get how
ejectives
I almost get pissed off and people will
have my map pissed off is if anyone has
my back god bless him but you know when
I was being called a racist and
someone's like well he has a Jewish
grandmother he's married to Hispanic
woman I'm like that shouldn't matter
yeah like just come at my idea I'm not
gonna do that whole like my piano
teacher my whole life was transcendent
or any of this [ __ ] like I know all
about that [ __ ] and it's like but I
don't want that to be an answer to an
idea because that goes against my whole
ethos like the you're right the least
interesting thing about you is being
gay and being Jewish yeah I guess I like
your where your brain is yeah but in a
weird way it's like it's just an
effective way of fighting back with them
sometimes it doesn't seem effective
anymore like Ben Shapiro's and Nazi I
mean that's insane like that's he's got
like a circus tent
yeah like you like it if it doesn't get
more or less I know you had a Jewish
grandma oh yeah yeah yeah so right so
that's it's just kind of basically we're
through the looking glass at this point
yeah so do you think that actually some
reason and all the other things that
we're talking about here do you think
we're starting to win because I am
starting yeah I do major signs of
regaining the narrative yeah and I think
that the young young people I have a lot
of hope for because a lot of these
people come to my shows I'm talking you
know 20 21 22 year-olds and they're
alive again and they're talking about
liberty and talking about things that I
was fortunate enough to never have to
battle as a kid I think as it wasn't as
threatened as it is now and I think that
there's a real back swing away from the
Millennial you know dead eyes of
trolling the internet all day and I
think we're gonna be okay and I have a
new admiration for conservatives because
I think conserving the original founding
fathers were the ultimate progressives
and to conserve that is so important
that's that's a point Crowder made to me
about what conservative means it doesn't
mean because I I thought it meant just
not changing and and he was like no it's
it's it's conserving the original
Constitution and founding ideas of the
sovereign individual and that's the most
progressive thing you can be and I found
that to be amazing you know so I don't
know who your favorite founder is but
Thomas Jefferson I was just a person and
he writes I mean if you look they have
these five or six giant texts on the
wall around his statue and one of them
you're right he was a progressive in
that he wanted people to change with the
times but at the same time he was a
conservative because he wanted them to
respect the original documents yeah
exactly
and I would say defending my liberal
principles is now a conservative
position it's not a it's not a leftist
position my liberal stuff right who's
defending me it's concern
so all of these things change over time
yeah and that's another thing is it
because I haven't changed very much on
my type of comedy it's just I think
leftism has gotten to the point where
they've just burned so many obvious
institutions and just made everything
chaos and now I seem very very
right-wing and it's like if if you go
back I don't know though I don't know if
it's like this Keyser söze situation or
like was it always like this and I just
didn't know it but I was always raised
that the Republican was the boogeyman
under my bed and that like they were
trying to take away gay rights and kick
poor people in the face and my
upbringing was my dad yelling at
macneil-lehrer about the goddamn
Republicans and I was and then you see
who has your back in times of crisis and
who will pick you up at the airport and
who you know and you're like oh it's
people that just focus on individual
rights and there's corruption on all
sides you're saying all your drivers
that your fantasies they have that being
a Republican that's what you're telling
me here I don't even know what they are
I just know that they're not leftist
yeah because it's like because they
always eat themselves they have a job
they said exactly yeah one of the things
that I like to ask stand-ups is do you
were there guys that you thought were
like incredible truly telling the truth
crossing that line when necessary all
that stuff that just disappeared because
I some of the best comics that I knew
just couldn't take it anymore they just
couldn't take the life the grind all
that something got out and I know guys
that are very average some are whom are
pretty crappy that actually succeeded
and there's every version of that of
course yeah for sure
III most of my friends in comedy have
done pretty well because I started in LA
like so I think a lot of them have
either ended up on TV shows or like
doing pretty well and some of the ones
that sucked are doing really well yeah
but uh but what does that tell you does
that is that you think a personality
trait or an ability to sell out a little
easier or just give them what they want
well I think it's a focus on marketing
over the art and I think like because I
would be on shows with people that
couldn't come close to following me I
mean I'm closing with classical piano
after establishing I'm a solid stand-up
it's like I might as well do a backflip
and it's like and I'll see some of those
guys rock it up and I was never envious
because I knew what it was I'm like oh
you've you've figured out a very
specific market you have some weird
identity thing to like appease the you
know the progressive gods you know
you're left handed handed a lesbian from
Sri Lanka you know like some [ __ ]
and then you figure out the marketing
and I was never good at marketing but I
could just always do stand-up very well
and I was always had a great crew like a
you know like my friends have always
helped me I'm very fortunate it's much
[ __ ] that's happened to me in the
last month like I've had some breaks
that you just can't imagine like Adam
Sandler watching me do stand-up and
putting me in a movie like that was my
childhood idol yeah you know Sandler is
just the best and so as much as it sucks
right now for some of the [ __ ] I've gone
through my life has been very very
fortunate you know it's funny have you
seen all of his Netflix movies no family
he's got so he's got this new deal with
parts not even new anymore but this deal
over the last five years or so so a
couple six or eight movies with Netflix
and a few of them in my humble opinion
we were pretty crappy but this last one
that he did sandy Wexler it's about this
washed-up you know basically comedy
Agent Hollywood agent yeah he like got
back to a lot of what made him so good
all that time it had some heart and all
that well I think one of one of the
things about Sandler's is you went to
appealing to the globe instead of just
America which is like all is like he's
making more now than ever yeah and it's
like when we're shooting Jack and Jill
duh
you know just on set he's the funniest
dude ever and you know that he didn't
lose a step in his comedy it's just
sometimes he writes for the world and
not like because sometimes comedy is so
good when it's very personal and very
like my life my niche and like you know
he knows that it's a global marketplace
and sometimes you just have to do a lot
of big physical gags do you do you think
success is sort of the the downfall of
all comics I don't mean this amount
Sandler specifically but just that in
general I can you see so many guys that
then you know they're so great that fire
burns so bright and then they become
something else
and then I genus is lost I think it's
when their goal is success that because
you know look at Trey Parker look at
Bill Burrell okay
Norma Donald like they were unimpeded by
success and so and then you see a bunch
the opposite where it's exactly what you
say we're like the Jim Carrey joke where
it's like I can still relate to
everybody so I'm banging nine super
bottles and the ugliest is like save it
from my face Jim you know because it's
like your problems don't relate anymore
but when you see it as like a craft like
Sebastian Seinfeld like these guys I
think that it only helps some you know
like South Park is doing some of their
best work and they appreciate their
billionaires you know it's they've gotta
be right but like success and money is
actually an obstacle sometimes to art
because now you have you know you can't
grow as much you have people staring at
you you know there's more stress but
some of these dudes can really handle it
yeah also the hunger I think it's just
sort of natural success success grows
and grows and grows the hunger the
struggle you know I heard George Carlin
let's talk about how it's like you need
all of that [ __ ] and that pain and
angst you need that for a certain point
to be a great comic and then at some
point if you don't own that it'll
ultimately destroy you which is why you
still see so many comics dying hour
flies and killing each other yeah yeah
yeah yeah like lately like now that I
don't have a safety net I've been doing
some of my best [ __ ] like I'm doing like
live streams on YouTube I'm started at
patreon more podcasting because it's
like I have an infant son and a wife who
doesn't work so it's like well she works
obviously as a mom but so when I'm put
in that when you backed me into a corner
it's like the wounded deer jumped
highest and I think that like that
hunger that I felt when I was a 23 24
year old busboy in LA I'm almost
regaining again in my mid-30s and trying
to get just a direct connection to my
actual fans which is pretty pretty fun
yeah what do you think people don't know
about the life of a comic like
everyone's heard the road stories the
amount of time you are alone and how
that can destroy your brain because like
you you see the light the guy or girl in
front or Zyzz or whatever you see yeah
let's yeah whatever you identify as but
you see them in for all these people and
then you see the love they get
and the hugs and high-fives and the
drinks and every other hour was just
staring at the back of someone's head in
a plane being in a hotel missing your
family you know wondering if you can
jump rope on the roof to try and can you
get a green smoothie somewhere so you
don't get fat and diabetes you know that
I was gonna do a whole show called
downtime which was everything else
because that'll kill you like isolation
kills animals and humans are very
communicative social animals and if you
put someone in a little room by
themselves they can go kind of nuts
I remember for like the year that I was
really doing road work and I was mostly
in New York City I opened for a weekend
we did six shows over three nights for
Bobcat Goldthwait just that's nice and
he's a great comic I actually didn't
know you know I thought of him as the
police academy guy I never really knew
him as a comic his documentaries are
sick yeah and but that was that was I
hadn't seen any of them till after this
but I did this weekend with him that he
was at bananas in Poughkeepsie not too
far from as we go somewhere it's
somewhere up there in that area and it's
a-you know but it's in a Best Western
Hotel sort of in the middle and oh yeah
but to me it was like the greatest gig
that I had ever got and I'm doing all
these shows and there were hundreds of
people and I couldn't leave it but I
remember one of the nights I think the
second night after the second show I'm
like you know we get standing ovations
it's great I'm saying hi to all these
people I think I signed my first
autograph I was so excited but then I
end up in my hotel room alone at a Best
Western like 3:00 in the morning
I'm starving there's nowhere to go the
juxtaposition makes even worse yeah and
I ended up going to the end of the
hallway and getting skittles and eight
skittles in bed at 3:00 in the morning I
remember this is a nightmare
actually yeah oh and the bigger you go
the bigger that drop is like I closed
Carnegie Hall with Vince Vaughn you know
I'm touring with those guys he asked me
to be his closer because I do a big like
journey thing it just couldn't be bigger
and then you're alone again and it's
like if your day goes like this it
doesn't hurt as much as it goes like
that
yeah and when I was featuring for
Swardson I was always like oh this is an
easy life because I didn't have to do
morning press and like when you wake up
at 5:00 a.m. and you don't shut off till
2:00 a.m. like there's no possible way
your sleep pattern is basically like
special-ops war [ __ ]
and like you can't sleep right and so
then people start taking pills to go up
and pills to go down and before you know
it you're dead yeah
what's your journey thing Oh why I do I
and my new feed the bear special you can
get it vimeo.com / yes no but like I
will link to it down below no I know but
I just do it's kind of funny to plug
stuff just take it's like it's like so
classless that it's funny to me this is
like 1960s you know you could have a
shirt on but yeah we're merged if you've
read that nor McDonald's new book no
yeah it's you gotta read it he talks
about how he's always wearing is his
dirty hat shirt and his S&L he's that
was pretty smart yeah but um so I I do a
bit where I talk about how I'm not
living my first dream like I wasn't
competing Kamiya was my third dream I'm
like my first dream was to be a real
like ballad guy you know but people just
kept laughing you know and so I I have
the crowd pretend I'm a real ballad guy
so I like instruct them when to laugh
and when to know not to laugh when to
clap when to sing along and so I do back
then I was doing journey and so I'd be
like just a small town girl and everyone
would be like ah and then Vaughan had
come out living in a lonely world and
Kevin James had come out you know took
the mid net and then faizon love and
we're all doing this big dance routine
and it was just when you tell the crowd
to do something they will do it and then
they'll actually feel a feel and there
and then I'd call yah was a Nam England
with the Impractical Jokers in January
and we're doing 12,000 seat stadiums and
I'm doing the same [ __ ] right and so I
started calling my fireflies because
they'd it would just be the o2 arena
just except I was doing over-the-pants
hand job in a Walgreens as my closer but
it was to Coldplay and it's like because
it sounds funny but then within 30
seconds they're like I feel emotional
and I'm like yeah that's like motion is
what creates emotion it's almost as if
social media should be actual social
people in a room together doing
something together yes it's almost as if
that oh yeah because when you do that
there's so much communication is
nonverbal and tone that's what gives me
trouble on Twitter because like my tone
and my demeanor always makes it feel
funny I think not always at bomber
but typically you know where I'm going
with it but a non-print I can sound like
a psychopath you know because I love I
love sarcasm I Chuck's position irony so
you know someone was like I'll be right
up like do you think if students were
forced to read mine comp like would that
be better for you know school kids or
something this is like today I was like
well I read it every morning but that's
a joke but you have to kind of see the
glimmer to see it yeah and if you don't
see it you might be like does this dude
read mine cause every morning maybe
Twitter might need like a new you know
now they're going to to 80 characters is
just a nightmare like you did was anyone
like I want more tweets I don't even
want the 280 I liked I like my
limitations do it but as her as a writer
and a and someone that cares about words
there's a beauty to the 140 if they told
me they were making it 70 I'd be okay
but going the other way seems like that
is exactly what we don't want through
the mortality of man is why our life has
meaning
like imagine if we live to be a thousand
it's like every year at be like I if I
get like 140 keep it tight
I was this little sidebar but since we
were talking about journey I got narked
at a journey concert in Orange County
outdoor arena I was like a pilot with
some friends we got busted like two
years ago where they say they came over
in this era or do you smokin drop a bomb
my friend you know through the joint way
and we they didn't kick us out but we
were scolded at an outdoor journey
concert what is what's the Miller Band I
mean legally I thought you had to smoke
by they're like you have to yeah they
hand it out I mean how are you supposed
to think about being on a magic carpet
ride I know that's not them what's the
one fly like an eagle fly like an eagle
yeah they're like fly like an eagle more
like be on the ground like a turkey I
said something about Turkey's being I'm
landlocked so there's no tarragon that
was really funny I don't know what that
was the least
Turkey expertise you could possibly have
and I respected that about you I said
I'm a chicken guy I'm not a tree turkeys
swim out of them and to probably do who
knows
what have you been able to steer clear
of all the bad side of comedy the drugs
drinking all that kind of stuff well I
mean I drink but I'm you know I'm a
red-blooded American man
a firepit in his backyard and a wife and
a baby you know that's what we do yeah
but uh yeah I never had a drug problem I
did coke a couple of times I just kept
having like business ideas that would
suck honey man we could just have a
flower shop yeah and it just never drew
me I think you know depression would
kick in or like I don't know but no I
never really was close to death or
anything because I think I was raised to
kind of do comedy so it isn't I'm not
like like a Mormon Mormon who's trying
to do the opposite of their awful
parents or some [ __ ] because they were
beaten you know like my dad teaches
public speech my mom teaches children's
lit which is basically how do you boil
down an archetype to the simplest
possible thing is children's lit and
that my dad is how do you speak it
without being scared yeah her dad ever
has he ever invited you to a class oh
yeah I was raised yeah why I will have
you ever done stand-up like for a class
or anything like that I just gave a
speech to the living writers group at
SUNY Oswego like two months ago or a
month ago because it was right before
the the firing from UConn and and like
it was such a weird juxtaposition
because it's like I got all these
letters of how much they liked my speech
and how all this [ __ ] and uh and then
with this other college this and I can't
talk there was just like who's pulling
the strings yeah what kind of groups
invite you to schools for me was always
comedies from being in the House Bunny
you know it was like like sororities was
would sponsor something or like and
having an agent I didn't even know it'd
be like oh here your offers blah blah
and now I've been getting emails from
like libertarian groups or Republican
groups and stuff and I find that so
funny I just never thought that that was
gonna be me like that those groups would
would invite me and the other ones would
think I was problematic it's hilarious
yeah I mean welcome to my world man I
mean every invite that I get is from
usually from libertarians students for
liberty and freedom this and and
conservative groups and I get nothing
from Democrats or liberals they don't
care about the gay thing the pro-choice
no thereon do against the difference
gendered toddlers bro gays are the
patriarchy it's like ah and it
the cool my wife pointed this out she
was like your fans are now like really
smart and engaged like literally I'll
just post anything and they're like well
I happen to be a nuclear physicist yeah
you know they just did they're also like
50 will taga joke better than I can
avert a get and it and I I'm not going
into this in insecure so I see it as
this like unbelievable resource of
information and like I do a podcast why
didn't they laugh about like why jokes
don't work and people used to be like
fans of it kind of but now all of people
like right spreadsheets of like what
could work and I'm like Oh individuals
are much smarter yeah so basically we're
boiling all this down and I mean this
really all comes down to the individual
versus the collect that's the whole
thing it's it's individual versus
collective and you can call it any
political party you want but that's the
split because I know Republicans that
think collective and they pissed me off
too it's not like there's a clear right
answer I just no leftism is not the
answer and then everyone else I just
have to figure out do you believe in an
individual autonomy or do you think
you're defined by the group that you're
associated with and I think the group
stuff is you know pretty much usually
leads to genocide so we'll see yeah it
always leads to Jen always a lot of
state power always leads to Janice
always or any of that stuff that it has
to Liberty yeah
it's like a look at even like some like
Venezuela or some of these socialist
plans it's like Marx it Marxism is
perfect as long as there's no people
here the problem yeah it is because
human nature itself needs competition
and they will always establish a
hierarchy so it's this wonderful
altruistic utopia and Lester's human
nature so eventually that algorithm will
start getting rid of what makes it not
work which is people and they all in
Stalin did it Mao you know pull pot you
know people that don't get 50 Netflix
specials a year like Hitler what like he
gets more Netflix specials than Bill
burr at this point that guy well you
know he's got a good publicist thank you
yeah Hitler in kale yeah
weirdest Trump speaking of Hitler where
does Trump
I think Trump's just uh he's a he's a
response he's uh he's uh you know he's
an agitator he's a guy that was I I I
was against Trump in the beginning and
then I saw that a lot of this does this
this fire-and-brimstone ever happened
and they keep acting like it's happening
and I'm like are you guys crazy like
he's the first president ever elected
that's pro gay marriage the stock
market's up
we're not rounding up Muslims you know
he tweets like a jackass he tweets like
a Twitter on coke Eddie's a X he has an
embarrassment element but the same time
he was kind of shattering this PC thing
that was happening so I think that he
just is what he is you know he's kind of
like this eccentric narcissistic guy
that is in my opinion better than what
Hillary Clinton would have been and the
libertarians need to get the [ __ ]
together and yeah that's that's what it
is is that the libertarians got to get
there well some well that's the thing
it's like for me it's like as I said I
love that Thomas Jefferson stuff and
it's like that's the guy I want the guy
who understands that but they don't get
a lack with the guy like we need someone
to be like now that I have power I want
to limit my own power which is so hard
to find someone to have those
simultaneous personality traits you know
it's like how do you get someone in
office it's willing to pull back the
federal government's expansion because
that's the part of the right-wing I like
is limited government individual freedom
but it's just like Bush was expanding
the government it's like all these guys
they'll say they're right wing but then
they just do the same [ __ ] that the left
is their doing and that's what I'm like
how do we get around that it's almost
like absolute power corrupts absolutely
and unless you're over 65 in which case
very good I mean we've been powerful
since birth I'm still depressed about
the 6-7 basketball thing it seems like
such a waste of height that's what
people said that's why I go up to short
people and I ask them if they get shot
out of a cannon and when they have it I
get real disappointed that's a waste of
cannon ball size yeah yeah you know
you're gonna have the the little people
lobby after you well a lot of them like
me because I balance them out like they
jump on me we have adventures carrying
them on my back
little master-blaster mad
kind of thing exactly yeah that's pretty
good I feel like we did a little bit of
everything here did we miss anything
I mean we could just keep talking I mean
well you're doing Rogen tomorrow eh I am
yeah you know you do a three-hour thing
with him look you gonna get high with
him or you don't you don't smoke the
weed I smoked a cage
he hasn't smoked in a month so I think
there's really no way around smoking
weed with him tomorrow I'm a little
behind has he not he took October sober
October and he yeah and so I'm gonna go
on a limb and say we're gonna smoke some
weed I'll smoke weed but for me it's
like um like I had an edible on Joey
Diaz his podcast and I kind of lost my
mind like not in a bad way but I just
kind of wandered off during the podcast
and never came back and ever since then
but that was like 200 milligrams of THC
that's a lot that's a lot but ever since
then I've been a little uh I don't know
I'm well nervous to like smoke and try
and talk well I always saw guys that
were like really doing a ton of drugs or
smoking a ton of pot and all that that
we're doing stand-up I always thought
you're just gonna keep opening up doors
till you could never get back you know
you know for me it was like I could open
up some of those doors but then I was
like all right I need to like have some
semblance of sanity to be playing yeah
it's like where's home base yeah like
are you just now coming from like you
know and Tim Ferriss had a good phrase
he's called he said there's always a
biological man I'm like a biological
debt it's like you know rather it's
human growth hormone or adderall you
know it's like if you go up like
whatever you just made mm has to be paid
back somehow you know rather it's like a
hard sleep crash or like you get like
fat boobs you know like something's
coming right you know I got friends who
took a lot of steroids and now they have
like no balls because their balls are
like I guess you're gonna need us
anymore
yeah that's pretty pretty crazy my balls
are too important to me yeah dude I love
them that boss yeah that seems like a
fitting and I'm gonna let you pimp out
the Vimeo him I'm gonna pimp out your
website but I want you you know you can
even do it dirt you wanna do it directly
to the camera yeah of course so directly
because this one the right one right
there right right there hi if you've
liked me today or tonight I don't judge
when you watch you can go to huge
pianist calm which is my website or
Vimeo
calm /o in' Benjamin to get my new
special feed the bear feed that bear
baby it's gonna be a long winter and I
was gonna go to huge pns calm I had it
right there I was gonna say I just
wanted to say it really but nice thank
you for that you pimped it out yourself
so you know it I instead I'll pimp out
your Twitter it's at Owen Benjamin it's
been fun man
thanks for having me thanks an honor
[Music]